hollywood legend glenn close has been
wowing audiences for nearly
50 years she has more than 100 tv
movie broadway credits but she says her
latest project for netflix
has everything she has longed for close
stars as family matriarch mamaw
in hillbilly elegy which is based on the
best-selling memoir
it tells the story of three generations
of an appalachian family
struggling with complex dynamics
financial hardship
and addiction in this preview mama
teaches her grandson jd a powerful
lesson
after learning his addiction-prone
mother could have her nursing license
revoked you may be right about some of
what you said
but things haven't exactly worked out
for your mama
and we can't let them take her license
why
it's your own stupid fault i know this
ain't right honey but she's your mother
and maybe if we help her this one last
time she'll finally learn her lesson and
keep her job but why can't we let her
clean her own mess up for once
because family's the only thing that
means a dam
and glenn cloyce glenn close joins us
now good morning glenn thanks so much
for being with us
this is an amazing transformation you
made into mama both in terms of playing
the part but also
you spent hours in the makeup chair
right
well funnily enough not that long that i
didn't have a lot of makeup on we
a brilliant prosthetics maker matthew
mungle
did a very subtle change to my nose and
it gave me much bigger ears as the real
mammal had and that was about it and
then uh erin mccashy was a
as a master um makeup artist she painted
the skin
you know so it was it was not that hard
it took me about
only about an hour to get ready what is
it like to look in the mirror
what is it like to look in the mirror
and not recognize yourself i'm telling
you i did not know that was you
i knew it was you because it said glenn
close but didn't i didn't see
any part of glenn post when i was
watching that portrayal
it's really freeing i mean i wanted to
go
that that freeing because you don't have
i'm not distracted by my own face
knowing that uh people are seeing my
face
and and i think um i mean i did it with
albert knobs and and with cruella you're
when you get in the full
drag of these wonderful characters who
aren't like you at all it really is
helpful
is that is that blended you know is
glenn is that why you say this is
everything you long for in a film is
that what you mean by that
well what i long for is first of all you
want to have a wonderful piece of
writing which i think this
was you want to have a wonderful
director who sets the stage and gets
a a stellar crew together
and um then you want to have a character
that's new territory for you
new emotional psychological territory
and i've never done a
character like mama and then to have a
my fellow
actress amy adams who's at the top of
her game
again you know with people of that
strength around you you find
you're you're free to just you know find
new things and be
bold and you know do it all together but
i had
an extraordinary woman to learn from to
get into this role
with with family videos and a lot of
pictures and
certain portraits of mama um so we
we tried to not you know be her
but but to find the essence
we're looking at side by side pictures
of you there with the real mama the
family was actually
on the set for part of the filming and
from what i understand got quite
emotional when they saw you
they did it was i was just hanging out
with my baggy shirt and my cigarettes
because she smoked
all the time sometimes two cigarettes at
the time
and her her older son came on the set
have you known
about three quarters away from the
shooting and he had to leave because
he's
he started crying i mean it was like i
mean he felt that she was
reincarnated in front of him and it was
a huge i was very gratified about that
you said that you thought she's loved
she's an archetypal
matriarch the movie is so good i really
enjoyed the movie
it got me thinking about different ways
of that part of the country
and the people that live there and i
thought that that was interesting to see
but you have said you wanted to dispel
the hillbilly cliche
what do you mean
well just very subjectively um we have i
mean there there's so many cliches about
about where they live how they live how
they talk
uh you know um and
this was just a family
i mean who moved yeah when when memo was
only
13 to southern ohio for a job and also
she had gotten pregnant
so this is for me um the more you zero
in on a very specific story
about a very real family the more people
can bring their own
you know baggage to it and or their own
stories and for me it was interesting to
just
what ron did just concentrate on the on
the on the family
and then thinking you know what chances
have they had
um how can how do you break those cycles
that they're caught up in
and how do we understand uh each other
better through telling stories like
glenn you mentioned another character
you could just disappear into was was
cruella de vil you
you recently recreated for halloween
recreated
cruella de vil which was really
wonderful
it was for a charity how much fun was
that
it was great my my my niece shona who's
also been my producer through all this
um she's been incredible and she was
i got the wig off the internet and went
down to a local
halloween shop and got some gloves and i
painted a chopstick red with a magic
marker
got some fancy you know long silky
underwear for my
thing and it was it was funny i wanted
to be very
white so i got some baby powder realized
that's the reason why that powder isn't
used for
makeup yeah i like the behind the scenes
secrets of that
i love it it's amazing what you can do
at home but glenn close thank you so
much for being with us this morning
hillbilly elegy is available in select
theaters and can be streamed on netflix
today